sasha it has been a long time coming i'm
excited to talk to you thank you for
having me
for people who do not know where did the
idea for nightgowns come from
five years ago well it actually all
started with
this magazine that my partner johnny and
i started producing in brooklyn it was
our way
to like get to know the local scene and
also
to merge our two worlds of drag and of
illustration and design and photography
and so we started this project that
celebrated all the different
styles and artistry of drag trying to
create drag
for the printed page i guess and we
ended up just throwing
a party to help sell the magazine found
a bar that would allow us to do it
and the bar owners basically said like
that was such a great show would you
consider doing that every month
and that was the birth of nightgowns it
started small and just kept growing
and my time on drag race just fueled my
passion
and like my maybe ambitions in some ways
with what nightgowns could be and now
it's a quippy
documentary it just kept going we're
transforming
the system that doesn't work for us
meticulousness is the thing that has
made her successful everybody was just
obsessed with the series when it came
out
tell me how did it feel to have it so
well received by not only your fan base
but also critics
i mean because it's such a personal
project for all of the performers
and then to share it with everyone and
not just what we share on nightgowns
which is the
kind of polished surface beautiful
performative side of drag but
to kind of be bold enough to pull back
the curtain and show
like some of the insecurities some of
the nerves backstage
um some of the unfinished um imperfect
aspects i think that was
kind of something really new for all of
us we aren't interested
in the world as it is we are interested
in the world
as it could be nothing feels more alive
than that i think i know the answer to
this but tell me are you game for a
season two
hello yes obviously i think we would
know just what to do with
it oh every time we have an opportunity
to put on the show we try to deliver
well big exciting news on august 9th
there is going to be
a three hour digital drag performance
live stream called night gowns forever
featuring
30 incredible sets from some of your
favorite drag performers
sasha tell me how did it feel to go back
and watch some of these old
performances from you know even five
years ago i
imagine it was kind of emotional for you
it was amazing when we were getting
ready for the
for the season on quibby we tried to
gather all the archival materials they
were like
mainly on one hard drive they kept
changing hands and when it came back we
realized with so
much material like incredible
performances
from three years ago two years ago just
from a couple months ago
and the star of those performances was
the audience in many ways and the
amazing interaction that always happens
at nighttime
between a performer just like bringing
their best the gorgeous life that i try
to keep for them
and the audience screaming their heads
off and i was like
we could really turn this into something
all this footage that we just had
i love that the event is free of charge
because they be entertained to feel
things right
that's exactly it but for those who are
watching and can make a donation it is
going to go to some great causes for
black lives
and black trans lives um sasha i love
that thank you for doing that
tell me when you look at the state of
the world right now
in 2020 you know there's a lot going on
there's a lot of movements in grassroots
protesters and
activists using their voice are you
feeling hopeful
absolutely like you said hopeful i i was
standing
in the sea of many many queer people
just a couple blocks away outside the
brooklyn museum for the
brooklyn action for black trans lives
which was organized in part by
a drag artist west dakota um who
whose performance appears in nightcast
forever i
feel hope that um there can be
real substantive change and i'm excited
for the ways in which in our own
communities
like we are trying to think of what that
means
not just talking about it i think people
are gonna see some real changes
i'm i'm gonna be a part of it so i'm
excited
as a friend of shae um you know she
spoke about in all stars five how
the rose petal moment kind of affected
her
everywhere she went anything she did she
was very affected by that
um tell me as a friend shea is in
nightgowns forever
how did it feel to see her finally get
her crown
you know this is part of my my
like anti-capitalist drag i feel
is a resistance against like the idea of
one person winning a competition there's
really no place for that
like in in my vision of drag i've always
in my gowns i spoke to speak about like
i don't believe in the idea of a
reigning plane there should be a royal
court
and i think it is my greatest pleasure
to see
the top four of my season one by one
each get
the crowns that we have all deserved
from the beginning peppermint is a
hunter
next i mean i expect her to just go
ahead and win an emmy or tony instead
but the drag race crown is definitely
hers as well
the world feels better now that jay
coulee has a drag race crown
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos